let's go to the white house and the
briefing room where peter ducey is
asking a question let's watch
what specifically is the president doing
about this so uh we just talked about uh
uh the day the overdose awareness day
that
that we are observing today uh i just
laid out uh what the second gentleman uh
and others are doing
within this administration uh and um
you know we are going to continue to
focus on the
the steps that we're taking that we have
taken you have the 80 million dollars
that dhs just announced today on drug
prevention and the president has taken
many steps he's made this a priority uh
to make sure that we attack a very uh
dangerous uh very dangerous drug serious
drugs in this country but 300 overdoses
a day now we know how the fentanyl is
coming into the country it's coming
right across the southern border
the dea administrator says so so when is
the president going to do something so i
will say that uh
you have seen a 200 percent increase of
fentanyl seizures which means that uh we
are we are doing the job of catching
drug traffickers 200 percent hold on 200
percent increase just again
seizure deficiencies are going down
at a rate not seen in a century and part
of that is being driven by drug
overdoses so what is the president and
we agree we agree we agree we see those
some same numbers as well but the fact
that we're you know we are securing the
border uh the fact that we are securing
record levels of funding
from dhs so they can stop illicit drugs
from entering into the country this the
fact that it's not just drug traffickers
that we're dealing with as well we're
stopping stopping finance shares this is
what's happening with this under this
administration
300 overdoses this is being designed to
target children drug cartels in mexico
want to kill american kids what is this
president doing about it i hear you i
just i just laid out 200 percent of
increase of drug fentanyl seizures that
is a dangerous drug that we are taking
off the street we are going to continue
to focus this is an important important
priority for this president and i just
want to talk about how you're saying
that they're you know they're just the
the border right and how the border
whatever you just stated i just want to
clear this up migrants
coming in people are dying
hold on so migrant migrants who
attempted to enter the country illegal
illegally are taken into custody by
border patrol agents that is how it
works that is the process that we are
taking they are then either expelled by
the court order under title 42
transferred to ice
custody or monitored through
alternatives to detention program as
they await further processing we have
made three thousand arrests in the first
three months of launching an aggressive
campaign to combat the multi-billion
dollar human smuggling industry when it
comes to when it comes to what's
happening with drug overdose this is
something that the president cares about
this is something that the president has
laid out a plan to make sure that our
kids our babies our
you know young americans here in this
country are not continuing to suffer
from that or not continuing to be given
or access to drugs this is something
that's incredibly important to this
president so to say that we're not doing
enough peter it's just falsely
categorically wrong especially on a day
that we are observing what needs to be
done and and we have announced dhs has
announced 80 million dollars to prevent
that so we are doing the work and here's
the thing peter if look if republicans
want to help us stop overdose and stop
our kids getting overdosed because of
these dangerous drugs because of these
fentanyl that we're seeing in the
streets we're happy to work with them
but they're not i'm moving on
i'm moving on i'm moving on
good
good getting okay yeah okay hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else